hi this is John Roca for Collider here
with suffer suffer Osmonds or is that
right alright let's first of all let's
just say this Bruce
second of all congratulations on getting
this film made how incredible has this
journey been for you for when you wrote
the book to seeing it now on screen and
getting that blessing from the beloved
Bruce Springsteen I mean it's it's it is
I say this and I say it's a dream come
true and that's the kind of cliche it is
a dream come true but it's kind of
bigger than a dream that you can really
imagine so either way my dream would
have been to write the book you know cuz
that's enough that's enough right right
to get a chance to write a book where
you get to tell your story that's a heck
of a thing you know
and so the book greetings from Barry
Park I was really pleased and proud with
it
and when I was writing it I was thinking
if somebody was to say what is your
ultimate dream it would be to try to
make a film out of it but you know you
know this I'm sure more than I do the
number of people who are you know
working on scripts oh yeah they never
happened I mean but I should tell people
I'm gonna thinking about it and they
would they would sort of look at me with
a with a sort of an element of pity
sympathy little bit of contempt right it
was just like why are you even bothering
telling me when you know this isn't
gonna happen you know yeah but watching
the film that seems to be something
you've constantly someone telling you
what you doing why are you bothering
it's not gonna happen I know yeah you
think you get the message by now yeah
yeah no it's true it is true and the
real reality is it's a ridiculous idea
of what's actually happened yeah I mean
the thing is it's almost a film in
itself isn't it the idea that somebody
from that background could now be
sitting here in LA talking to you about
a feature film yeah here's the thing
that's kind of crazy is to make a film
is kind of amazing right there's no much
effort yet but to make a film that then
he's actually on the radar and people
are noticing and st. nice things about
ya and then to make a film there people
are noticing and you've made that comes
from that kind of background and he's
actually quite good yeah I mean there's
a there's a possibility you could go all
this for
the film could have been absolutely crap
right right but it's actually quite good
they've got about a 10 minute 5 minute
standing ovation yeah this is fantastic
you know 93 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
and so do you think that I mean the odds
of just making the film are you know a
pretty bad - actually it's actually a
really good film
yeah and it's sort of connecting with
people I mean it's like you feel like
you've liked won the lottery really one
thing I wanted to ask you about is the
relationship with your father I'm I'm
the son of immigrants as well to this
country yeah of American immigrants yeah
I saw so much of your story edge I story
yeah being a nerdy kid walked around
with his headphones yeah and I
discovered born in the USA at the same
time Wow I knew nothing about
Springsteen until this was a big deal in
Rolling Stone right
so when when what happens in the movie
happens how much of what we see between
you and your father was even more brutal
in the relationship that's a really good
question I mean in a way it was worse
yeah in some ways so for example in some
ways it wasn't so for example in the
film there's a concert in 1988 and Javad
can't go in real life actually went to
the concert or no problem right what
there was a bit of a problem but I went
I went everywhere because it was just a
new question that was going to go what
in terms of writing the script we were
thinking about it was just like well
there were so many issues and so many
arguments so I just thought what we can
dramatize them all in one event right
rather than breaking them up well give
me an example I was not allowed out of
the house ever I didn't go out the house
until I went to university at 18 Wow in
the evening so no I just it was just
never gonna happen so there was no
girlfriends I just double stat was
completely made up for the purposes of
like you know wanted to try and make the
hero have a habit you know have some
have some love interest that was totally
not even a thought that would have
happened you know so in that sense
things were worse but also the other
thing about it is you know I was really
careful and I wanted with the film is
not to make the father a monster yes and
I think that's what's really easy to do
in films like this is you know
especially when it's that then that the
next that when it's the son or the
daughter who gets to tell the story it's
easy to Hannam simplify and stereotype
justify
this isn't it wasn't being a
one-dimensional mustache twirling and
never yeah yeah and they're just plastic
obstacles right there just obstacle
irreal II they had to be an obstacle
because I was filmed ISM you don't go
film but I really wanted there to be no
bad guys in the film yeah and so I think
Calvin dagger who plays him I think he
does a really good job and we try to do
it with the story as well off making it
feel like you could see where he was
coming from yeah you might not agree
with him everything but you can see that
he's trying the best through the way
that he sees the world yeah did it help
you reappraise [ __ ] your dad because was
out when I was sitting there and I don't
want to ruin the movie obviously but
that scene in the kitchen know he breaks
down the other man I started crying in
the theater thinking of my own father
and his struggles that he must have gone
through his immigrant to put food on the
table and clothes on our backs yeah well
that's the very interesting so when I
was writing the book the first draft of
the book the dad was very very
stereotypically harsh and then I thought
carrying on I was like you know what the
job of a writer is to be empathetic yes
so I've got to try and see it from his
point of view and then I started
thinking okay so this is a guy who he
came to Britain in 63 my mum and me came
in 74 so for eleven years he was living
as a single guy suddenly his wife and
three kids come along he's like 40 and
he suddenly a father of three and he's
never had any experience of that and
what their burden must be like yeah yeah
and then what's it like to have that and
then lose your job right right so that
sort of level of empathy and the
interesting system to where the film is
there's a speech that towards the end of
the film which job it makes and where he
sort of talks about a lot of these
things the interesting thing about that
is that I lost my dad when I was 23 and
I did not have that wisdom when I was 16
yeah yeah that speech is me talking
about my dad now that's including it in
job it's mouth right let's talk about
one last thing and that is was there a
Bruce Springsteen song that inspired you
to write the book because you it's as
2004 when you finally write the book so
you know you're not just writing it
right out of college or nervously but as
we see that in the movie how much that
inspires him to do the things he does
well I mean there's a song called the
promise yes the promise I love the front
so there's a line in their way says I
hit it big ones but I
the big cost inside I carried the broken
spirits of all the other ones who lost
that is a really important line for me
because I think that's what Springsteen
does yeah and in a sort of way that's
what I was trying to do with the film
and the book because the truth is most
people don't get out right of their
situation right they don't find their
way out they don't Springsteen talks
about that yeah and so what I was trying
to do was to honor and remember the
broken spirits of all the other ones who
lost well it's a fantastic remembrance
of them and an honor of them so I love
the movie for that and I look forward to
the sequel will be based on Tunnel of
Love I can't believe this alright this
is John Roca for Collider with the
lovely and awesome sun rays Mansour
thank you so much